[Musique]
la 37e édition de miel vert a été lancée
ce vendredi 3 aujourd'hui à la plaine
des cafres organisé chaque année durant
les vacances scolaires sur les tiges
mulberry le premier événement de l'année
sur l'île en rendez vous incontournable
où l'on retrouve des produits 100% pays
site une réussite qui est exceptionnel
et nous y ajoutons la diversification
agricole de tout cela ap les cafés
devenue élue elle accueille justement le
grenier de la réunion que nous
produisons plus la moitié delà des
besoins de notre population
le département tient pour compétences
agricoles est effectivement présent pour
soutenir les agriculteurs à l'occasion
de cette 37e édition de miel vert et
miel vert qui est la vitrine des
agriculteurs la vitrine des produits du
terroir et du territoire est ce
effectivement l'engagement du
département aux côtés des professionnels
aux côtés de la filière agricole entière
que nous sommes puisqu'il est important
pour nous de soutenir les producteurs
les agriculteurs ceux et celles les
hommes et les femmes qui sont passionnés
par ce qu'ils font qu'ils savaient
qu'ils adorent leur métier qu'ils sont
là pour nourrir la population
réunionnaise
près de 600 à 1200 tonnes juste en
accueille les visiteurs
les producteurs espèrent encore
avec le public de l'ombre l'occasion
pour eux de démontrer leur savoir-faire
d'être en contact direct des
consommateurs la même chose que l'année
dernière le beaucoup de monde beaucoup
de prêts fréquentation et puis partager
avec les gens qui viendront nous voir un
lecherpy culte est la première
production c'est le miel et j'ai aussi
quelques produits de la ruche produits
dérivés je fais aussi de la propolis
je fais des bas des pistes le fait aussi
de sirop à base de miel que cuba
cannelle gingembre
j'espère que les gens prendront
conscience que
on a plus des magnifiques produits et
que ben il vaut mieux privilégier la
production locale
c'est de l'extérieur voilà afin de
promouvoir le terroir et le savoir faire
créole des animations débats et ateliers
sont également proposés dans miel vert
on a la chance de mettre en place des
animations vont connaître un petit peu
la vie des producteurs des agriculteurs
mais aussi la vie du consommateur
cela va nous permettre d'améliorer nos
différents dispositifs alors sous forme
de jeux à très ludique
ils vont découvrir un petit peu les
différents métiers leur culte heures des
questionnaires pour connaître un petit
peu comme en consomme le réunionnais est
cet ensemble d'activités va nous
permettre d'être de plus en plus de la
performance est d'aider la population
réunionnaise en fait notamment sur les
fruits et légumes en 37e édition de miel
vert se poursuit jusqu'au 12 janvier
prochain le rendez vous à ne pas manquer
[Musique]